i think courage is external right the
reason someone has courage to jump out
of an airplane is because there's a
parachute on their back it's the
external thing
a a a a world famous trapeze artist
would never try a brand new death
defying act for the first time without a
net it's the net that gives them the
courage
you know the navy seals are considered
one of the highest performing
organizations on the planet
and a former seal was asked what kind of
person
makes it into the seals
and he said
i can't tell you the kind of person that
makes it in but i can tell you the kind
of person that doesn't make it in
he said the star college athletes
who have never really been tested to the
core of their being
none of them making it
he said the preening leaders who like to
delegate everything
none of them make it in
he says the guys who show up with
hulking muscles covered in tattoos
because they want to show you how tough
they are
none of them make it in
he said he said some of the guys who
make it in are skinny and scrawny
he said some of the guys who make it in
you see them shivering out of fear
he said but every single one of the guys
who makes it in
when they're emotionally exhausted when
they're physically exhausted when they
have absolutely nothing left to give
somehow some way
they're able to dig down deep inside
themselves to find the energy to help
the guy next them
in other words
the reason these organizations and these
people have the courage to do remarkable
things is not because of their internal
strength it's because they have the
absolute confidence that there is
someone to the left of them and someone
to the right of them that cares about
them
um and they all know that and it's the
quality of the relationships that we
maintain
professionally and personally
that give us the courage to do difficult
things
isaac stern the famous violinist said
music is what happens between the notes
well something like trust happens
between the meetings
you know we
few people think about the importance of
building trust when they go to work or
the what i need to do today to build
trust with somebody like that doesn't
really go through people's minds but we
have chit chat as we walk into the
meeting we chit-chat when we walk out of
the meeting and we see somebody in the
hall and they're like oh
meant to tell you something or you knock
on someone's door and be like got a
minute and all those little
innocuous interactions over the course
of time like any relationship
build trust
it's about
setting up the computer and setting up
zoom and having a work session with
somebody you know like we're not working
on the same thing but i want to work
with somebody a work buddy or having a
lunch with somebody over zoom or a
monday morning huddle where we talk
about what's on our heart and minds but
we do not talk business on purpose or
friday cocktails that are just voluntary
but the most important one is to just
pick up the phone and call people and
say how are you
that level of empathy
just check in on someone and i think we
neglect it because we get mired in the
day-to-day but you know one of you know
if you're organized or disorganized you
know literally keep a list of your team
on a little card next to your computer
and just
you know go through it and have i called
this person a while and talk to the
spread i'm just going to call and check
in it doesn't matter if something's
wrong or not wrong
just check in on them you know don't
wait for something to break
um and
let people know that they're uh
that there's connection and there's a
way to reach out and say i need help
um
because if if
and and the most important thing is for
leaders to be honest and open about
their need to ask for help
and that
that'll work